these guys want to talk about JK Rowling
is that so what's going on with that
what do you want to know uh she's she's
had a pretty controversial past I just
want to know like what are your thoughts
on it check out this is a teacher
debunking just so brilliantly a student
who accuses JK rling of being
transphobic and you know you know about
this story we've covered it quite a bit
JK rling all she has said JK rling who
of course created Harry Potter all she
has said is that you shouldn't have men
and women sports and things along those
lines there's biological differences
between men and women all the stuff that
we all knew was true 10 years ago uh
anyway it has become sort of part of the
internet that she's now transphobic and
these people are trying to write her out
of new Harry Potter stories it's all so
stupid anyway this kid asks the teacher
about JK rowlings transphobia and
controversial comments and just watch
this so these guys want to talk about JK
rowlings is that so what's going on with
that what do you want to know uh she's
she's had a pretty controversial path
asked I just want to know like what are
your thoughts on it and like do you
still like her work despite her uh biged
opinions so let's get specific though
let's define bigoted opinions what
opinions are bigoted we're going to
treat this as a thought experiment I'm
not going to say what's right or wrong
or what way to think the whole point is
to learn how to think not what to think
yeah so when you say big you you're
you're starting with the conclusion that
given her bigoted opinions so first
let's start with does she have bigoted
opinions so when when you say B
she has had a history of being extremely
transphobic I've heard you've heard so
what can you give me an example uh if
you look at her Twitter I think you
could see a few things um if you want I
could try and find something see if you
can find see if you can find one so one
of these tweets that she came up with in
2019 she said dress however you please
call yourself whatever you like sleep
with any consenting adult who will have
you
um live your best life in peace and
security but Force women out of their
jobs for starting that for stating that
sex is real so you find that bigoted
what do you find about it there it was
deemed
transphobic like I myself do you find
that transphobic yourself uh I don't
really have an opinion on it but I'm
just going with what a lot of other
people have said okay so we're going to
show you a bit more in just a second but
do you see what this teacher and you
know we we can make fun of teachers all
the time and our education system has
been demolished and we have activists
not teachers and as the teacher points
out there too much too many places of
Education are teaching them what to
think instead of how to think but did
you see the way he systematically did
that it was a surgical strike let's get
specific what's bigoted does she
actually have bigoted opinions give me
an example so okay so then he gives the
example and now you can see the kid
already is suddenly waffling well now
check this out so let's pause it let's
not go with what other people are saying
let's try and learn how to critically
think so let's analyze the Tweet
ourselves so that statement do you see
anything problematic disregarding other
people's opinions
um she did try and
pin some things on a spe A specific
group of per of people I where where
dides she do do that can you read that
but Force women out of their jobs for
stating that sex is real so when I hear
that I'm interpreting that is meaning if
a woman says that you know saying that
there's a difference between men and
female and then being attacked as
transphobic I think that's what she's
saying by attacking someone for stating
that sex is real that is exactly what
she's saying is that transphobic to you
so to me no stating that sex is real is
not transphobic it's just a fact of life
it exists so is there anything you
disagree with in that
tweet uh in that tweet I can't really
see anything that I myself disagree with
but I can see why some people would
think oh this is offensive we can't have
that here or something cuz how why do
you do you think it's fair that there's
a that she's being being attacked by a
large group of people and people are
calling her like you said at the
beginning of this conversation you said
given the fact that JK Rowling is
transphobic how do you feel about Harry
Potter now retroactively looking at that
statement do you think that that was the
best way to phrase no I feel like an
idiot now it's okay though but this is
why we do this to learn to learn how to
think do you see how beautiful that is
like absolutely beautiful when you
calmly question people make them think
for yourselves that's exactly what he
was doing the entire time like why are
you saying these things what do you
think and then by the end the kid is
basically like oh she's not a
transphobe